はじめしゃちょーと
あっちそっちよっちです..あぶぅ
皆さんYouTubeで今　わかります？
今見てるこの画面が皆さんで言うYouTube
で、YouTubeって動画を見る前に
よっち：はい
サムネイルというものがあるじゃないですか
よっち：あります
どんな動画なのかっていうのがわかる
一つの画像としてサムネイルっていうのが
動画を見る前に皆さんクリックすると思うんですけども
そのサムネイル
色んなYouTuberは動画を見てほしくて見てほしくて
動画を作る時間よりサムネイル作る方に時間をかけてる
よっち：たしかに、そっちも大事です
よっち：ごめんなさぁぁい
(´;ω;｀)
ま、一番大事なのは内容ですよ
内容も大事なんですけどもサムネイルも動画を見てもらうために
大切な要素になってきます
ということで今回はサムネイル対決ということで
サムネイル対決ぅ～
どっちがより優れたサムネイルを作るか
お題を一つ出されるので
お題に沿ったサムネイルを作るという対決です
おあ＾～いいですね＾～
はじめ：なるべく
よっち：なるべく
見てもらえ...ﾊｸｼｮﾝ!!
なるべく見てもらいたくなるような
「わっ見たい！」
「なんだこの動画」
みたいな
よっち：なるほど
というゲームでございます
審査員は今、奥の部屋にいるUUUMの社員さんがいるので
よっち：なるほど
UUUMの社員さんに審査してもらって
どっちが優れたサムネイラーかというのを
証明しようと。
最初のお題は
（笑）
よっち：たまご食べてみた　？
ま、YouTubeで求められるのは
いかに盛るか
いかに..いかに盛るか
という戦いです
制限時間10分で
よっち：はい
はじめ：スタートです
よっち：もうもうもう写真撮ってる
はじめ：完璧です、そこそこと
はじめ：白バックだと抜けるんだよねすぐ
よっち：これはいいっしょ
よっち：ハッハッハッｗ
OK ヘーイ
はじめ：ま、そうなるね
はじめ：たまご食べてみたって色んな攻め方あるからね
よっち：あ、なるほど
はいというわけで出来の方いかがでしたでしょうか
よっち：30%って感じです
30%?
まずはじゃあ見せてくれ、よっちから
よっち：じゃあ私から
イキますよー
私の作ったサムネイルはこちらです
ドン！
あー上手いね　なるほどなるほどｗ
上手い！
よっち：上手いですか？
はじめ：上手い！
たまごだけじゃちょっと伝わりずらいんで
本物の鶏をポンッと置きました
おおー上手いな
あと口..僕の口をちょっとデッかくしたって感じですかね
はじめ：なるほど
素晴らしい素晴らしい
はじめ：いやーこれいい勝負かもしんねーなー
よっち：いい勝負っすかねー
僕のやつはこちらです
はい
（笑）
はじめ：いやーこれあの
よっち：あーお姉さん卑怯だわー
YouTubeで大切な要素2つ含んでまして
1つは女の人です
男の子はね女の子いると見たくなっちゃうから
ひょっとして手渡しで貰った卵を食うのかなっていう妄想が膨らんでしまって
ついつい”たまごを食べてみた”という動画を見てしまう
で、あとはやっぱね大量系
大量にあったら見たくなるんすよ
よっち：ご飯粒みたいになってますけど
よっち：いやー僕もお姉さん載せようと迷ったんですよ
難しいとこだねこれは
よっち：これ載せようとしてました
( ^)o(^ )
よっち：釣りはやめましょう
はじめ：はい
いやでもこれ決めるのは審査員ですからね
たまご食べてみたって動画あるとしたら
どっちのサムネイルの方が見たくなるかという
社員：なるほど
せーのっ
はい
（笑）
はじめ：どっちすかねこれ
社員：わかりました、選びました
選んだのは
よっちです
イェーーーイ
はじめ：まじ？うそーーー
イェーーーイありがとうございます
クソォォォ
よっち：うーわまじか勝っちゃった
よっち：ていうかあの、釣りはなしだって言ってましたけど
よっち：思いっきりお姉さんで釣ってましたよこれ
はじめ：いや、このお姉さんが作った卵なんだよ
よっち：wwwそうなんすか
はじめ：俺の中では
はじめ：自分で見返したらやっぱダメだなこれ
はじめ：ご飯食ってんじゃねぇかww
2本目よっちお題出していいよ
はじめ：な　ん　で　も
よっち：じゃあ分かりました
よっち：なんのドッキリかはおまかせします
はじめ：あーなるほど
はじめ：あのー題名ではなくサムネイルで勝負するタイプの
よっち：そうですね
はじめ：あーなるほど
制限時間は20分
スタート！
よっち：いやダメダメダメ、ブサイクこれ
はじめ：自分で笑っちゃってんのw
はじめ：いや俺もすごいからね
よっち：これはやばいな
んーグッジョブ
はい終了ーー
お疲れ様です
はいというわけで2本目なんですけども
はじめ：出来はどうですか？
よっち：出来はもうあのー僕はもう満足です
はじめ：まじ？
よっち：まじでです
はじめ：じゃーーよっちからいこうか
はーい
はじめ；画素数荒くね？なんかw
はじめ：これは見るね
よっち：これはー
はじめ：こういうことやってるやつらいるもん
はじめ：そっちで攻めたか
はじめ：いい勝負だと思う
よっち：いい勝負ですか？
僕のサムネイル
ドッキリしてみたはこちらです
はい
（笑）
よっち：ちょっと待ってw
よっち：待ってこれ
よっち：ちょ待って待て待て
よっち待ってこれ　え？
はじめ：まじ本当にさっきの時間で作ったからね
ま、要するにオイラがちょっと連れてかれた、怪しい女の人に
で、服全部剥がれて
で、本当に命の危機を感じるドッキリという
よっち：これ無理w
はじめ：方向性が違うじゃん
はじめ：そっちは完全にそういう
はじめ：男心くする感じ
よっち：男心くすぐる
はじめ：こっちは本当に
はじめ：え！？みたいな
よっち：言うたら結構女心くすぐりますよ
（笑）
よっち：普通のメインチャンネルで上げてそうな感じ
はじめ：しねーわｗこんなんのしねーｗ
では早速審査の方に入りましょう
よろしくお願いします
今回のタイトルは
ドッキリしてみたです
社員：なるほど
せーのっ
はい
（笑）
はじめそこは難しいすよねw
よっち：これは
社員：うーんなるほど分かりました決めました
では結果は
結果は
はじめさんの方
よっっっし！！！
よっち：いやーこれはこれは僕も見たいすもんなんか
インパクトやばいっすｗ
（笑）
はじめ：結局YouTubeのシステム上見れないからさ
はじめ：覗けないですもんねYouTubeで
はじめ：こっちもギリYouTubeで見れないラインを走ってるんですけども
これは負けたわぁ
はいというわけで今回の勝負は1対1の引き分けということですね
よっち：ンアー(≧Д≦)ありがとうございます
よっち：良い経験になりました
はじめ：またいつかしようこれは
よっち：またいつかしましょう決着つけましょう
はじめ：もっと色んなYouTuberはもっと色んなの作れると思うので
よっち：たしかに
はじめ：またいつか勝負しよう
よっち：勝負しましょう
はじめ：いやーいい勝負だったよ
よっち：ありがとうございます
はじめ：また戦おうではないか
よっち：また戦いましょう
というわけでまた次の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな！
じゃあな！どわぁぁ
デデドン（絶望）
痛い痛い痛い痛い痛かった
痛い痛いｗ